Jack since you say you are new to
youtube i'm not sure if you'll remember
back in like maybe 2007-2008 when it
seems like it was easier to get views
it's a very competitive space now and i
know we talked about you know briefing
what are you coming up against cuz
you're you know your trailer is just
gotten a lot of views i mean it's not
easy to get get one that has like 18,000
yeah well yeah it's uh it's interesting
i think that you know you can put
because this is a company they benefit
of doing something at a company is that
the company you know we'll have some
marketing money to promote so there's
there's money in house or in the company
to promote certain things and you sort
of have something at the bottomless
bucket of money you just have to say
okay then take a little bit of money and
promote this episode of trailer hitch or
this episode of badass digest or what
have you and not everything gets the
same sort of marketing push so something
that has a little bit of marketing
behind it it's like an independent movie
like if you have some money to submit to
festivals or some money to make a poster
or even if you have a little bit of
money to like book a theater and screen
it for one night that gives you the edge
over over a filmmaker who has nothing
and it's just sort of hoping that
somebody discovers their movie but i
don't know i think it's infinitely I
think it's infinitely competitive I
think it's like worse than any other
media platforms worse than TV's worse
the movies simply because anybody
anybody can put something on YouTube so
it's this ocean or this galaxy of stuff
that means that there's like probably
tons of really cool stuff out there
there's also tons of really bad stuff
out there and then it becomes like well
how does a viewer including myself how
do you find it how do you how do you
find it and you relying upon somebody to
point you in that direction I don't
think I don't think there are many of us
who necessarily click on something
because we see an ad for a video usually
it's somebody says hey like check this
out like where you got to see this or
maybe if you're searching for something
you can in a search bar but it is this
sort of
random sort of very sort of like check
this out thing and I don't know is amiss
it's sort of a mystery to me I mean I
think of you to put your video up on its
main page which is the equivalent of
like you know being on the cover of a
magazine then you're guaranteed to get
more clicks but i don't know i don't i
just sort of hope I mean the philosophy
has always been if you make great
content that it will find an audience
and I think I have to believe in that
because that's the only thing I can
really control like and that goes for
any weather making a film or TV show or
whatever you cannot control what an
audience is going how an audience is
going to react whether they're going to
come and even if you make a big movie
and you advertise the out of it and
you spend 80 zillion dollars on TV
commercials and billboards and you know
magazine ads that doesn't mean on Friday
night that you're you know you can't
literally pick them up with a forklift
and put them into the theater you still
there's this intangible thing about like
well as raining I don't want to go you
know like so it's a weird thing i don't
i don't know i just i all i can do is
make hopefully make something that's i'm
happy with and hopefully it gets shared
enough so that people get to know about
it and watch it you know but I don't
know I really don't know it's so much
stuff out there
you